il a toujours aimé faire le clown et ce
soir il se produit pour la première fois
en one man show jamel debbouze un jeune
comique a pratiqué le théâtre
d'improvisation puis touché au cinéma ce
soir dans sa ville de trappes il
présente son nouveau spectacle c'est
tout neuf cent portraits avec loïc très
bon et je me fais lumière dit c'est que
la télévision régionale pour la police
nationale
euh je peux marcher tout seul par la
tenue d'une poussée suisse depuis les
sites choisis et sylvain tessier pas
parce que tu es grande tu me fais peur
parce que tu es fort si les toits
spector je vais pas vous étudiez coeur
je peux vous appeler ton temps je suis
inséré comme il faut je mets mes parents
que sont marocains qui ont grandi au
maroc qui sont venus ici littéraire en
france
et moi j'ai eu aucun problème à ses
mains serrées dans la mesure où j'ai où
je suis né ici c'est à paris et non à
barbès dans le tas lariboisière
les journalistes ils arrivent ils à fait
comme ça écoutez jamais je ne vais pas y
aller par tâtonnement je vais les droits
comme 800 contourner la question
je veux vous parler en toute franchise
de vos problèmes économiques sociaux
culturels entre kkr je sais vous avez
d'énormes problèmes à vous insérer
parlement parmi les gens normaux
je sais que votre père car votre mère et
que vous en est réduit à vous servir de
cali des caddies comme moyen de
locomotion dit sentais pas que c'est pas
vrai j'ai des preuves ans je me suis
lavé grave je prends le bus il m'arrive
une galère j'ai être tout de suite j'en
fais quelque chose je mange avec ma mère
et des fois c'est c'est carrément un
sketch mes voisins de gaucher cc des
sketches à août où seule la vie à
trappes c'est un sketch où il joue bien
ça fait 3 heures il approcha la justice
la caisse qui cherchent un job en métal
peinte sur les trois grands concerts
récents bons chiffres
et il faut la trouver mais pas tout le
temps j'aime bien le dit qu'il décède le
matin ça dans l'apparat cosy assurément
un jour petit jamais elle deviendra
grand par la grâce d'allah peut-être de
sa foi sans jeux cadeaux